Guten Morgen liebe guten Morgen Tim.
Hoffentlich keine Beta.
Herzlich willkommen bei Lokbuchnetzpolitik, eurem Beta Podcast der der unvollendete.
Der ist vollendet.
Meinst du? Schon.
Vollendete Adprobungsphase.
Aber er hat noch keine Milliarde noch keine Milliarde Hörer erreicht und von daher äh kann da noch was passieren.
Also ich möchte vorsichtig schätzen, hoffen, das müssten wir eigentlich mal ausrechnen,
Wenn man jetzt überlegt, wie viel Leute, Podcast beim Reisen, beim Autofahren oder so hören? Würde mich jetzt echt mal interessieren, wie viel.
Kilometer gefahren.
Zurückgelegt hat, unfallfrei.
Das ist eine schwierige Hochrechnung.
Mache ich gleich meinen Excel.
Da kann man kann man da kann man sich ordentlich was aus den Fingern saugen würde ich sagen. Einfach mal irgendwas behaupten, das funktioniert ja eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Allerdings kann können unser Podcast noch nicht autonom euch steuern.
Nee, nee, nee.
Hätte ich jetzt echt nicht gedacht, dass du hier Witze über äh kaputte Autos machst beim Nähen.
Ob ich auch gar nicht.
Du weißt, da reagieren die Deutschen empfindlich.
Meinst du, ist gleich ein Thema?
Ja, das war ein Weltthema, ne? Also wir äh wir haben seit der letzten Sendung hat Tesla einen tragischen Verlust erlitten.
Nämlich einen großen Fan, der äh mit dem Tester Autopilot einen tödlichen Unfall hatte in den USA.
Ja, das ist natürlich sehr bedauerlich.
Bedauerlich und äh vorhersehbar gewesen, insofern in eine eine Debatte, auf die man war gewartet hat, dass sie stattfinden würde.
Ob es ums Auto geht, da ist Deutschland ja auch sehr sensibel.
Na, vor allem wenn's um Tester geht, ist Deutschland sehr sensibel, ne? Also was ist passiert? Tesla hat ja vor, wie lange ist das jetzt her, vor ungefähr einem Jahr, wäre jetzt so mein Gefühl.
Nee, noch nicht so lange.
Seinen Autos ähm einen Autopiloten spendiert. Die also ab einer gewissen Kategorie, du kannst ja dieses Modell S in.
Durfte man dazu kaufen und wenn man das Modell mit den passenden Sensoren hatte, dann war es eigentlich nur noch eine Frage eines Softwareupdates und.
Aber Geld gekostet hat.
Geld gekostet hat und wenn man das dann aber gekauft hat, das waren so ein paar tausend Dollar.
Fünftausend Dollar, dreitausenddreihundert Euro oder irgendwie sowas in der Region war das. Ähm.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht genau. Ähm dann, dann hat man halt so ein Assistenzfeature, wie man äh in Deutschland vielleicht formulieren würde.
Spurhaltungsassistenz heißt das, ne? Also du ähm.
Ist mehr als nur die Haltung der Spur. Es ist ja auch eigenständiges äh Abstand halten, beziehungsweise auch auch Ausscherden und.
Ich kann jetzt, ich bin ja schon mal damit gefahren, kann ich das vielleicht ganz kurz hier ich hab schon.
Ernsthaft? Mit diesem.
Ungefähr tausendfünfhundert Kilometer in einem selbstfahrenden Tesla zurückgelegt schon. Mhm.
Sage ich.
Nix passiert übrigens, ne? Also macht euch keine Sorgen.
Hast du, wie viel hast du dir die letzte Zeit geschlafen oder.
Ja, es vergeht wie im Schlaf, ne? Nein, also ähm,
Der Wagen hält Spur, Abstand und Tempo, wenn du auf einer Straße bist mit,
Fahrbahnmarkierung mögt bestenfalls auf beiden Seiten,
Kannst du also auf einer Landstraße machen, kannst du auf einer Autobahn machen. Der fährt dich jetzt nicht, autonom durch eine Stadt oder so, ne? Also wenn jetzt irgendwie in der Stadt bist, sagst pharmatonomed da und dahin macht der nicht. Der biegt auch nicht für dich ab oder sowas, ne? Der fährt,
Eine Strecke die vorhersehbar und definiert ist, die fährt ja für dich. Tempomat mit Mitlenkung an.
Ähm wenn du einen Spurwechsel, also wenn dann vor dir, sagen wir mal, ein langsamer, langsames äh langsameres Fahrzeug ist, dann bremst der ab und hält den äh vorgegebenen Sicherheitsabstand ein. Wenn du dann den äh Blinker betätigst,
dann macht er auch einen Spurwechsel und den macht er auch von alleine. Ähm und guckt dabei,
mit äh mit Sensoren eben, ob ob sich hinter ihm gerade was befindet. Ähm funktioniert ganz schön und wenn du
wirklich die Hände vom Lenkrad nimmst, was viele Fahrer machen, was sie aber eigentlich nicht dürfen, dann piept er nach ein paar Minuten. Also ich weiß nicht, die Zeit scheint mir nicht äh regelhaft zu sein.
Nur als das Auto merkt, dass man die Hände nicht am Lenkrad hat.
Ich bin mir also ich bin mir noch nicht mal ganz so sicher, ob der das der merkt das glaube ich sogar kapazitiv. Es gibt irgendwie in den USA so äh ich weiß nicht, ob das Tester war oder ein anderes Auto, aber da gibt's irgendwie so eine Geschichte, dass die Leute sich Bananen ans Lenkrad kleben,
kein Scherz.
Ich muss da mal den Link.
Ja, das wäre jetzt auch die naheliegende technische Lösung.
So bei äh hier habe ich eine Autobildartikel. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das bei Tesla war, doch ist ein Tesla hier, der.
Also Kotelette dran tackern und dann hat man so ein richtiges, schönes, selbstfahrendes Aut.
Ja also wie gesagt, dass wir das nicht ausprobiert, deswegen weiß ich das nicht. Du fährst damit und dann musst halt irgendwie so mal kurz am Lenkrad das anfassen, mal kurz bewegen, damit er sieht, okay, du bist noch da.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass du es wirklich bewegen musst. Ich glaube, du musst, ich glaube, er merkt es schon in dem Moment, wo du's anfasst. Ich bin mir da nicht, also ich.
Wahrscheinlich also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das Lenkrad relativ kleine Ging-Link-Maßnahmen schon bemerken würde und das Ding anzufassen ohne Kraft auszuüben ist wahrscheinlich auch fast gar nicht machbar.
Genau, deswegen weiß ich's nicht genau. Äh müsste ich natürlich eigentlich.
Ja, weil wenn du da so einen Lederbezug drauf hast oder sowas äh ansonsten wie ein Polster, dann dann versagt sicherlich diese kapazitive Geschichte auch.
Genau, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Aber das ist doch das, was wir hier am besten können, über Dinge reden, die wir nicht genau wissen.
Ja, also vielleicht kann ich ja ganz kurz, also das Auto fährt so vor sich hin und ähm,
hält eben Abstand, ist zum Beispiel auch ganz angenehm, wenn du in so einen Stau kommst, so einen Autobahnstau ist ja alle paar Meter, dann äh fährt der, macht der so dieses Top-and-Go-Assistenz, ne? Der, der rollt dann da einfach ganz gemütlich ähm.
Folgt. Mhm.
Schöne, schönes äh schönes Ding, natürlich auch so ein bisschen unheimlich und äh was auch ganz cool ist, wenn der dann äh irgendwie seine autonome Kapa,
Capability verliert, weil die Straße zum Beispiel zu nass ist und er die Seidenbegrenzung nicht mehr sieht oder weil die auf einmal aufhören oder so, dann fängt der diverse Pippi, dann musste äh selber lenken, ne,
Und ähm von den Sensoren her hat der, glaube ich, rundum Ultraschallsensoren und vorne und hinten eine Kamera und nach vorne auch einen Radar,
Ich glaube, das sind so die Sensoren, die er hat,
So und wenn du das anmachst, dann sagt er dir, hallo äh das ist hier eine eine Beta,
Du bist immer nur, wir helfen dir ein bisschen, die Spur zu halten, aber du bist hier immer noch der Captain und der Steuermann und du musst hier selber fahren,
und was jetzt ähm was jetzt passiert ist, ist, dass ein Mensch, der wohl in in Tessler Foren dann auch bekannt war, als ein großer äh Tesla Fan. Diese Fahrzeuge sind hier nicht besonders günstig zu haben,
Ähm da muss man schon irgendwie ein bisschen Geld für auf den Tisch legen. Ähm ein Fan, der äh nun.
Also auf einer Art Highway oder Landstraße fuhr und dann vor ihm ein großer Sattelschlepper links abbog,
Und der Tesla aufgrund der entgegenkommenden Sonne, den weißen,
Aufliegeranhänger dieses LKWs für ein Stück des Himmels gehalten hat und mittels seiner Radersensoren nur quasi die beiden.
Aufsitzer, Auflieger,
Ne, wo also da wurde die Räder wahrgenommen hat und dann dachte, ah okay, da fahre ich jetzt unter einer Brücke oder einem Verkehrsschild her. Fahr einfach weiter. Und ist dann ungebremst ähm unter diesen,
enger hergefahren und hat dann dabei wohl um den äh sein Da,
sein Dach verloren und äh auch Teile äh des Fahrers, der wie ähm berichtet wurde wohl damit beschäftigt war auf der eine DVD zu gucken. Hat irgendwie so ein DVD-Player oder sowas offen?
Das war eine Behauptung des Fahres des LKW-Fahrers.
Nein, das ja, also da das weiß ich jetzt auch nicht so ganz genau, ob der jetzt ferngesehen hat oder nicht, ist eigentlich egal, denn Tatsache ist, dieses Fahrzeug ist kein vollständig autonom fahrendes Fahrzeug,
wurde auch nicht als ein solches.
Gegenüber den fahrenden bezeichnet in der Werbung gab's dann natürlich schon irgendwie so äh Andeutungen, Tesla fährt jetzt autonom und auch die Bezeichnung als Autopilot ist natürlich etwas ähm.
Etwas überzogen.
Etwas hochgreifen, wobei das wahrscheinlich wiederum schon vergleichbar ist mit dem Autopilot eines Flugzeugs, denn das Flugzeug muss ja in der Regel auch selber am Ende noch landen und der Pilot ist schuld und da würde jetzt keiner sagen, der Autopilot ist schuld.
Ja, beim Landen, aber der Autopilot selber, der ändert ja tatsächlich seine Richtung und steuert das Flugz.
Der fliegt einen vorgefahrenen, vorgefertigten Kurs ab.
Ich also Äpfelbirnen. Ja. Hm.
Ja
Ja auf jeden Fall tragischer Fall jetzt äh Pilot äh Tod, Autopilot kaputt ähm und jetzt muss man sich überlegen, was ist da? Wie ist das zu bewerten? Die die Debatte wird natürlich hitzig geführt,
weil ähm,
Man eben hat so diese die Überlegung eben immer war, so darf die Maschine und wir haben ja hier auch vor einigen Sendungen schon darüber gesprochen, dass die Maschine jetzt eine Ethik bekommt oder so, aber die entscheidende Kennzahl ähm,
In dieser Angelegenheit hat Tesla,
die ich sehr ähm bemerkenswert finde, dass sie nämlich sagen, ja zu diesem Zeitpunkt hat das Tesla Out Autopilotsystem.
In den verschiedenen Fahrzeugen, die wir damit ausgestattet haben, schon einhundertdreißig Millionen Meilen verfahren
Die wissen das, weil diese Testers, also jeder dieser Testers hat irgendwie eine SIM-Karte über die ganze Zeit mit Tester kommuniziert. Du konntest ja auch tatsächlich
abends in der Garage klicken. Äh ich möchte jetzt den das Update haben, oder ich weiß nicht, ob das im Auto buchen konntest oder außerhalb. Ähm,
Und er hat ja das über über LTE sich das Update über Nacht gezogen. Nächsten Morgen hattest du dieses Feature. Die haben auch so Scherze wie wenn du jetzt an so einem äh Supercharger stehst
dann kriegst eine Push-Mitteilung aufs iPhone, dass deine Karre jetzt ausreichend geladen ist und so was, ne? Also dass dieses Auto sieht man ja auch schon in dem großen iPad, was die da ins Armaturenbrett geklebt haben. Dieses Auto ist
ähm sehr vernetzt und sagt natürlich auch die ganze Zeit zu Hause Bescheid. Es hat übrigens auch diese Lerndinge,
Ähm was du anfangst äh zum Beispiel haben viele berichtet, okay sie fahren jeden Tag die gleiche Strecke,
und an einer Stelle piept immer der Autopilot und sagt, ich komme hier, ne? Achtung, kenne ich nicht, lenke du mal.
Wenn das dann eine Woche gemacht hast und du fährst quasi an dieser Stelle jedes Mal das gleiche Abweichmanöver und überbringst den Wagen quasi beide lang zu fahren.
Dann lernt ihr das, ne? Fährt piept er irgendwann an der Stelle nicht mehr. Und natürlich piept nicht nur dein Tesla an der Stelle nicht mehr, sondern alle.
Und das heißt, die haben eine Selbstverständlich, so ist es eben heute, so wird es auch bei den autonomen Fahrzeugen immer sein. Ähm,
überwacht und mitgeschnitten, wo der Pferd ausgewertet, wie der Pferd, was die Sensoren machen, an welchen Stellen das System versagt und Menschen eingreifen. Das heißt, am Ende lernen alle Testers von allen Testers,
und daher wissen wir auch die genaue Anzahl an Kilometern, die ihr autonomes System oder ihr Autopilot da jetzt zurückgelegt hat,
und sagen na ja in hier ähm,
Wir haben hundertdreißig Millionen Meilen zurückgelegt, bis jetzt ein Mensch draufgegangen ist und in den USA,
haben wir alle vierundneunzig Millionen Meilen einen Todesfall. Das heißt, sie sind jetzt schon mal fast,
fünfzig Prozent weitergekommen ohne jemanden zu töten als ein äh als der durchschnittliche US-Fahrer. Dann gibt's natürlich ähm und weltweit,
Ähm, wenn jetzt alle Länder in Schnitt nimmst, hast du alle äh sechzig Millionen Meilen einen Todesfall.
Wobei man das jetzt mit dieser niedrigen äh Sampelzahl irgendwie noch nicht so richtig sagen kann. Also ich meine, es hat mir sozusagen den ersten.
Ja, genau, aber sie sind auf jeden Fall schon mal. Sie sind beim ersten Mal über einen Schnitt gekommen und diese Rechnung ist natürlich auch ein bisschen eine Milchmädchenrechnung, weil sie ja zum Beispiel die diesen gesamten Stadtverkehr,
außen vorlassen. Ich war der ist ich weiß nicht ob der tödlicher ist als der Autobahnverkehr.
Für Fahrräder auf jeden Fall. Ich kenne das ja eher so aus Fahrradperspektive.
Ohne ohnehin etwas schwierig so mit unserer Denke, da die amerikanische Verkehrsrealität ohne weiteres einz.
So ein bisschen.
In diesem Fall auch noch so Sachen mit dazu kommen wie, weil eben auch die Vorschriften für Lastwagen dort
was die Sicherheitsausstattung betrifft, etwas lachser sind, also in Europa wäre so ein Lastwagen eben nicht unterfahrbar gewesen, weil halt ein Unterfahrschutz quasi vorgeschrieben ist
Da wäre er halt dagegen gefahren, aber er hätte sich nicht äh den Kopf abgasiert.
Ja
Aber jetzt haben wir die Debatte, also jetzt haben wir die, jetzt haben wir die Debatte, die erste Phase der Debatte, die ist jetzt wie der autonome Fahren, jetzt wird lange diskutiert,
Das Kraftfahrtbundesamt hat dann auch äh ist Tesa zu Leibe gerückt, weil
sie dann sagen, das ist eine Beta-Software und dann hat das äh ein Sprecher des Kraftfahrtbundesamtes gesagt, wenn mit der Bezeichnung Beta-Version ein unfertiger Stand der Software gemeint ist,
Dann wird das Kraftfahrtbundesamt eine Funktionalität mit einer derartigen Software nicht genehmigen. Tesla hat dann jetzt heute entgegnet, nee das ist keine unfertige Software ähm,
Man schreibt überall Beta dran bei uns. Ähm.
Aber du hast also die, wir haben jetzt einmal diese Debatte und es wird nochmal eine geben, denn jetzt hat in diesem Fall hat das Fahrzeug ja nur seinen Passagier getötet.
Es wird noch der Moment kommen, in dem so ein Auto mit Assistenz oder Autonomiesystem einen unbeteiligten Menschen tötet. Dann werden wir nochmal eine nochmal eine Debatte haben.
Nachdem nicht autonome Autos massenhaft unbeteiligte Leute äh getötet haben und ihre Fahrer auch,
Also das muss man ja äh auch mal äh sehen, ne. Die These hatten wir ja auch durchdiskutiert. Das ist sozusagen schon zu erwarten ist, dass der Verkehr durch autonome Systeme,
insgesamt sicherlich sicherer werden wird so, dass es schon eine positive Also ist eine Voraussage von uns gewesen,
aber natürlich regt man sich jetzt erstmal auf über etwas, was man nicht gewohnt ist und deswegen ist halt die Diskussion auch so groß drumherum. Nachvollziehbar,
Und in Deutschland halt äh,
interessant, weil das Thema dann halt auf einmal aus dem Ausland kommt, ne? Als man ja auch nicht so richtig gewohnt, dass quasi die Diskussion des Zukunfts
der Zukunft des Automobils auf einmal durch ein Unternehmen geprägt wird, was halt nicht aus den USA, also äh Entschuldigung, was nicht aus Deutschland ist.
Ja, also die deutschen Automobilhersteller, die haben ja jetzt schon angekündigt, dass sie in fünf Jahren wirklich autonomes Fahren in Serienreifer haben wollen und man hört da auch ähm relativ viel.
Von ähm entsprechenden,
Projekten in den deutschen Ottobau, Großstädten ähm wo äh spannende spannende Moves von Autos gemacht werden. Ähm.
Also so Spurfahrassistenten, also Spurhalter.
In deutschen Autos auch schon.
Ja eben, das gibt's definitiv schon und.
Rückwärts einparken, Tricks gibt's auch schon.
Das ist auch schon serienmäßig, dass man so im R.
Serie sogar.
Ja, wenn's Autos kaufen, die einfach einparken. Kann ja jetzt gerade nicht die Modelle durchdeklinieren, aber das ist sozusagen schon.
Da fährt man irgendwie quasi neben eine Parklücke, setzt einen Rückwärtsgang ein und dann.
Genau der scannt und da sagt pack mal einen für mich und dann macht er das. Sehr langsam mit viel piep piep piep piep und so aber macht er halt. Da bekommt man dann ganz gut in Lücken rein, wo vielleicht manche sonst nicht so reinkommen würden.
Parkt er auch automatisch wieder aus. Mhm.
Weiß ich nicht. Ich fahre leider immer Autos, die sehr alt sind und von daher habe ich nicht so viel Einblick.
Die falschen Freunde Tim. Ich war schon in Tesla.
Zu wenig Sponsoren, ne? Schön Tesla. Tja, mich hat noch keiner eingeladen.
Kann ich ja mal. Arangieren.
So, hasse einen im in der Garage oder was?
Nein. Könnte ich mal auf die Amazon-Wunschliste.
Mein Drittwagen.
Die ich äh ja ich würde also das ist schon ein, ich ist ein tolles Fahrzeug, macht das äh macht macht große Freude, dieses dieses Automobil. Ähm.
Da muss man noch was dazu sagen. Ähm ein Tester hat ja dann auch,
eingeräumt, dass das jetzt nicht der erste Unfall war, die dieses autonome System gebaut hat, ist nur der erste, bei dem jemand gestorben ist
Es gab also auch noch weitere Unfälle und ich höre auch im äh Bekanntenkreis, dass die, dass das,
Auto auch teilweise komische Dinge mal macht. Also irgendwie so war die Situation, du fährst in eine Kurve.
Und dann macht in der Kurve von mir, also in der Kurve über hohe genau in der Kurve überholen, also bis auf eine Autobahn, du fährst
der linken Spur, du fährst schneller als jemand in der rechten Spur. Jetzt macht die Autobahn eine Kurve, in dem Moment merkt der Wagen, oh, da nähert sich seitlich was, ich fahre aber auch gerade nach rechts, ja? Also in der rechten Spur.
Rechtskurve ist.
Fährst eine Rechtskurve,
Also du fährst auf der linken Spur, warum auf der auf der rechten Spur fährt einer achtzig, du fährst auf der linken Spur hundert, ja? Du fährst jetzt langsam an die du breitest dich vorhin langsam an dem vorbeizufahren, die Autobahn macht eine Rechtskurve. Der Testaff hält also die Rechtskurve,
und sieht dann, dass rechts, also in der Richtung, wo er lenkt, sich auf einmal ein Objekt auf ihn zubewegt. Nämlich das Auto, was er gleich überholen wird.
Aber weil er irgendwie dann denkt so, öh, ich will dahin fahren, der ist aber da, das ist langsam, kommt auf mich zu, dann bremst der ab,
Ja, also er kann da nicht er kann offenbar nicht sicher mit Sicherheit unterscheiden.
Die Straße macht eine Kurve et cetera.
Machen eine Kurve, alles ist safe und da habe ich irgendwie jetzt gehört, dass er dann öfter mal irgendwie komisch bremst oder so und dann wird man in, dann macht er irgendeine komische Sache,
wurde mir jetzt zweimal erzählt, dass das irgendwie der Fall war. Habe ich aber noch selber noch nicht miterlebt.
Ja, das sind wieder diese Schmerzen mit neuen Technologien. Ich meine, wenn ich mir diesen Fall anschaue, klar ist halt immer dramatisch, wenn wenn jemand äh stirbt, aber vor allem war es ja erstmal,
seine eigene Schuld,
Weil ist ja nicht so, dass das Auto es ihm unmöglich gemacht hätte zu reagieren. Das ist ja nicht so, oh Gott, ich muss bremsen und der Autopilot hätte dann das verhindert, sondern es ist ja nur so, dass er quasi gesagt hat, passt schon und dann,
Weiß ich nicht, wie kurz die Vorwarnzeit war, also Lastwagen, der quer vor einem Pferd, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, was der Abstand da war und ob das überhaupt berichtet wurde, aber ähm.
Hätte er vielleicht mit etwas mehr Aufmerksamkeit auch äh anders ausgehen können,
Und so macht man das alles äh bewerten. Von daher, ich verstehe das, dass die Diskussionen dadurch aufkommen, weil Tesla halt jetzt so dermaßen gehypt wird. Finde ich auch sehr interessant, so mit diesem,
Beta-Ansatz, also der Name ist wirklich sehr unglücklich gewählt an der Stelle, ne?
Elon Musk hat ja dazu gesagt, das heißt Beta, weil's noch keine Milliarde Kilometer zurückgelegt hat.
Also er sagt, wenn es quasi, wenn die, wenn es eine Milliarde zurückgelegt hat, dann heißt es nicht mehr Beta. Und sie hätten auch,
Zu diesem Wort gegriffen, damit Fahrer es sich nicht zu bequem am Steuern am Steuer machen. Also quasi so Achtung, Warnung, das ist hier eine Beta äh nicht jetzt irgendwie nach hinten setzen und ein Schnittchen essen oder so, ne?
Oder DVD gucken.
Andererseits ist es natürlich so, du musst diese Fahrzeuge ähm die brauchen ja was zum Lernen.
Du wirst nicht ohne ohne eben Millionen oder Milliarden an Kilometern zurückgelegt haben.
Zurückgelegt zu haben, ein autonom fahrendes Fahrzeug auf den Markt bringen können,
Deswegen fahren die Google-Autos die ganze Zeit durch die Gegend. Ähm deswegen fährt äh Tesla diese Dinger durch die Gegend und deswegen haben auch die Tesla die neuen,
die die Sensoren drin haben, aber kein,
kein autonomes Fahren können, trotzdem die Sensoren drin, weil ich mir relativ sicher bin, dass die auch versuchen werden, von den nicht automatisch fahrenden Autos möglichst viel zu lernen. Das wäre eben das äh technisch gesehen,
angemessene Datenschutzrechtlich muss man sich da nochmal mit auseinandersetzen. Technisch ist es einfach das sinnvollste jegliche Fahrbewegung, die irgendeiner macht, egal wie die ausgehen,
Mit aufgezeichnet zu haben und daraus ein äh Lernen stattfinden zu lassen.
Ja
Als es passiert, muss man schauen, wie die Debatte weiterläuft.
Ich fand's sehr stark, also was mich daran interessiert hat, war, dass es jetzt so so früh die, also dass,
Das jetzt schon der Zeitpunkt ist, dass es diese Debatte gibt. Wie gesagt, es wird dann nochmal eine geben, wenn äh wenn eine unbeteiligte Person überfahren ist und dann wade es das aber auch mit den Debatten.
Weil dann sich nämlich rausstellen wird, dass es eben sehr seltener passiert, als wenn Mensch steuert und dann äh ist das eben durch.
Na gut, in Deutschland wird die Diskussion nochmal kommen, wenn deutsche Autos damit beteiligt sind, ne.
Ja, dann aber dann ist die Diskussion eigentlich auch vorbei, weil wenn deutsche Autos das machen, ist das gut.
Ja natürlich können wir uns doch als Volkswirtschaft gar nicht leisten.
Ach ja, na gut. Auch auf Autopilot scheint die europäische Union zu sein, was.
Deutschland muss ja erstmal noch eine Möglichkeit finden bei den Crashtest zu betrügen.
Tja, jetzt hast du mal eine Überleitung kaputt gemacht. Ja, ich kaputt gemacht. Hm.
Ja ja okay. Ja, habe ich kaputt gemacht. Ja. Okay, du wolltest eine Autopilot über äh ist durch, meinst du?
Durch der Witz. Ist deutlich meins. Na ja, soll ich jetzt das normal sagen? Nee. Irgendwas mit Netzsperren.
Irgendwas mit Netzwerken? EU-Netzsperren haben wir ja Antiterror und so, ne? Al.
Ja, ganz wichtig.
Ich glaube letzte Sendung haben wir da schon drüber gesprochen. Da nach Paris musste ja was getan werden und um den Prozess zu beschleunigen, zu beschleunigen hat man gesagt, das EU-Parlament,
Mach das einfach direkt im Innenausschuss, ähm in dem Liebeausschuss, bürgerliche Freiheiten, Justiz und Inneres. Und ähm der,
Innenausschuss hat jetzt am vierten Juli die Terrorismusrichtlinie abgesegnet, das ist jene,
die unter anderem Terrorpropaganda aus dem Netz entfernen soll, entweder durch staatliche Anordnung oder mittels Selbstregulation.
Und da eben die Netzsperren jetzt mit dem schönen Begriff,
Show äh definieren. Ergänzt elegal, Terrorist Content, Ondy Internet, Member States, Show, Take the Nesisery Mashes, Turnschuhe, Promcremovel,
Allerlei Kritik rankt sich natürlich dadrum, jetzt heißt es hier wieder illegaler Inhalt, das heißt, da haben wir gar nicht so einen direkten,
Terrorismusbezug mehr, ähm das heißt, das wird jetzt irgendwie unschön, das Ganze geht jetzt in die Trilogverhandlung, wie wir es äh schon in der vorletzten Sendung sehe ich grade ausführlich,
behandelt haben? Schön, ne? Also.
Ja, vielen Dank Frau Hohlmeier, die ja die Strauß Tochter, die hier die Berichterstatterin war im Liebe-Ausschuss und ja, was die CSU zu solchen Themen sagt, brauchen wir jetzt hier, glaube ich, gar nicht weiter zu diskutieren,
Das scheint da auch irgendwie so ein bisschen Religion zu sein.
Jetzt kommen wir zu der, zu der traurigsten Nachricht heute, wirklich eine äh traurige Nachricht,
das Hüpfreferendum ist,
Äußerst, äußerst, äußerst, äußerst, scheiße, scheiße, scheiße, scheiße, knapp gescheitert. Wir erinnern uns, das wurde ja angestrengt von dem Chaos-Computerclub, der Schweiz, der Piratenpartei der Schweiz und der digitalen Gesellschaft,
der Schweiz und vielen Einzelpersonen, die sich da engagiert haben und,
Am Ende haben nur wenige Unterschriften und einige zusätzliche Tage für die Beglaubiegung gefehlt. Ähm der Kira hatte das ja schon ähm erzählt.
Dass sie diese Unterschriften nochmal selber sammeln und beglaubigen lassen mussten bis zu der Deadline, also es reichte nicht zu der Deadline von mir aus,
Fünfundsechzigtausend zu haben.
Sie müssen dann auch.
Die mussten auch noch äh beglaubigt sein. Und sie haben dann mindestens fünfundvierzigtausend,
Beglaubigte also von den Gemeinden überprüfte Unterschriften eingereicht,
hatten aber fünfundfünfzigtausend gesammelt. Das heißt, es ist echt daran gescheitert
wenn jetzt nochmal den Schwund einrechnest, ne? Also zehn, wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, die hatten zehn Prozent Schwund oder so oder acht Prozent Schwung, dann hätten sie dieses dieses Quorum von fünfzigtausend nämlich erreicht,
und sie haben's nicht mehr zeitlich geschafft, die äh die noch beglaubigen zu lassen. Also das ist wirklich ähm,
wirklich, wirklich bitter und die haben ein Wahnsinnseinsatz geleistet und da also,
sammel mal fünfundfünfzigtausend Unterschriften, ne? Das ist echt eine Mordsarbeit. Und ähm wenn es dann wirklich an an so einer H.
Scharfen, kleinen Zahl scheitert, dann ist das sehr ähm sehr bitter,
Aber was mich am meisten beeindruckt, die äh verlieren überhaupt nicht ihren Mut dabei, sondern haben eine recht äh kämpferische
Pressemitteilung geschrieben, wo sie sagen, na ja okay, also der Staatstrojaner und die Ausweitung des Geltungsbereiches dieses Gesetzes, was,
des Büffs ähm die sind jetzt festgeschrieben und da kann man auch nix mehr machen gegen diese beiden Dinge im Moment
aber wir haben ja äh die Unterlassung der grundrechtswidrigen Vorratsdatenspeicherung gefordert und sind gerade mit unserer äh mit unserem juristischen Kampf dagegen los,
Das heißt, sie werden vor dem Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Sankt Gallen das nochmal verhandeln, wenn sie da unterliegen, werden sie ihre Beschwerde
notwendig nötigen Falls bis zum europäischen Gerichtshof für Menz, Menschenrechte hochprügeln.
Und im September steht ja auch die Abstimmung gegen das Nachrichtendienstgesetz an. Hier können also hier nochmal auf die Folge mit,
äh verweisen, wo er das alles nochmal genau genauer erklärt hat, sagen dieses Nachrichtendienstgesetz ist ja genauso grundrechteverletzend wie das Pupf. Und da,
gehen sie auch gegen vor und da wird verlangen sie dann, schlagen sie dann vor am fünfundzwanzigsten September mit,
nein zu stimmen. Also sie geben sich nicht geschlagen und ähm sind da weiterhin voller Kampfeswille und ich finde, das ist auch wahrscheinlich die richtige Lehre, die man daraus ziehen kann, wenn man etwas nur ganz knapp,
verfehlt ein Ziel, dass man eben daraus nicht der aufgrund dessen nicht aufgibt, sondern,
Ganz im Gegenteil, ähm daraus Kampfesgut zieht und weitermacht.
Also herzlichen Dank an den Schweizer Chaos-Computerclub Piratenpartei und digitale Gesellschaft und die vielen Individuen, die dabei Unterstützung geholfen haben.
Ach so genau und äh das habe ich jetzt glaube ich gar nicht erwähnt. Sie haben diese Unterschriften natürlich trotzdem jetzt eingereicht und aus dem,
ähm aus dem äh Referendum ist jetzt ein Wind heißt es, äh bei der bei Papa, eine Petition geworden,
Also sie haben das Quorum nicht erreicht und deswegen ist dieses Referendum jetzt eine Petition. Reichen sie trotzdem ein.
Das können wir machen, ja.
Ja, ist quasi, dass dadurch, dass jetzt die,
Die Zahl eingereicht haben und kann einreichen kannst du eh wird jetzt nichts mit passieren, aber es ist ein dokumentierter äh Fall oder ist ein dokumentierter Behördenakt, dass diese Unterschriften eingegangen sind.
Ja wobei Petition haben wir ja schon in Deutschland mehrfach äh erlebt und jetzt auch gerade wieder in Britannien, die werden dann zur Kenntnis genommen und dann geht's in die Mittagspause.
Ja dann, also sei eine ereignisreiche Woche gewesen,
erinnern wir uns ja dass Max Schrems, der ja auch bei uns inzwischen schon zu Gast war, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Ähm.
Ja. Ausführlichst.
Mit seiner Initiative Europe versus Facebook letztendlich ja,
Das Safeharber-Abkommen weggeklagt hatte, was die juristische Grundlage dafür war, dass äh,
da deutsche Daten europäische Datenschutzmaßgaben in den USA als grundsätzlich für erfüllt gelten, auch wenn dies,
objektiv nicht der Fall ist. Und jetzt dadurch, dass das,
Save Harbe Abkommen ja nun weg war, gab es eben keine Daten äh keine,
Keine rechtliche Grundlage mehr für diesen Datenaustausch bitter. Täglich millionenfach stattfindet und man musste sich etwas überlegen. Deshalb wurde ja dann das EU.
Privacy schielt. Ähm,
Verhandelt und einen Tag vor Ablauf der Deadline irgendwie bekannt gegeben, dass man sich geeinigt hätte, aber irgendwie der Inhalt nicht so wirklich bekannt gegeben,
Und sowohl die,
Datenschützer der EU-Mitgliedsstaaten als auch der EU-Datenschutzbeauftragte haben dieses neue Privacy Schield eben bereits kritisiert und gesagt, okay, da ist nichts anderes, das ist einfach
Das Gleiche, es gibt keine Verbesserungen beim Schutz europäischer Daten vor US-Geheimdiensten und dieses vor US-Geheimdiensten war ja der
entscheidende Punkt. Ähm mir ist dessen ähm Marx Schrems eben dazu beigetragen hat, dass äh dass,
Safe Harbe Abkommen in seiner, der damals vorherrschenden Form nicht akzeptabel war.
Und auch was die EU-Datenschutzverordnung im Prinzip wieder richtig auf die Spur gebracht hat.
Genau. Ähm spannend ist, dass diese.
Dieses Privacy schielt, da haben also jetzt die, also die EU-Kommission hat das mit den US-Regierungsvertretern ausgehandelt,
Österreich, Kroatien, Slowenien und Bulgarien haben sich enthalten. Alle anderen haben dafür gestimmt.
Und jetzt ist kein ähm Beschluss seitens der USA erforderlich, weil ähm,
die ganze Kommission sich mit diesem Privacy Schield nur auf in in Briefform erfolgte Zusagen der US-Regierung beruft. Also sie haben einen Brief geschrieben, haben gesagt so und so sieht das aus.
Und dann haben die gesagt, ja okay, alles klar, dann äh dann können wir ja jetzt hier äh abstimmen.
Jetzt kommt noch ein Punkt, also der Europäische Gerichtshof hat in seinem Urteil zu dem Safe Harber Abkommen festgelegt, dass das letzte Wort bei den Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörden,
liegt. Und die können werden jetzt unabhängig darüber befinden müssen, ob und inwieweit sie der Kommissionsentscheidung folgen wollen.
So hat es das Gericht in dem Safe Haber Abkommen formuliert.
Wie genau aber dieses Rollenverständnis gedacht ist, ob jetzt die
ob jetzt die Datenschutzbehörden der einzelnen Länder quasi höher als die Kommission stehen oder was auch immer darüber herrscht noch so ein bisschen Uneinigkeit und es ist ja ohnehin so, dass jetzt die einzelnen Länder im Zweifelsfall nicht
Sagen wir nee, wir machen aber jetzt nicht mit, weil das ja wiederum das Problem wäre. Du kannst ja nur,
gemeinsam als EU stark sein. Aber widmen wir uns mal der genauen Kritik an diesem EU Privacy Shity kommt natürlich von dem Experten in dem Bereich Max Schrems, der sagt,
Einige Lücken sind zwar geschlossen worden, trotzdem ähm,
Ist man noch weit von dem entfernt, was in Europa der Standard ist?
Das wäre ja eigentlich das Verlag. Das ist ja das, was so ein Abkommen macht, zu sagen, wir haben einen Standard und unser Abkommen sorgt dafür, dass dieser Standard gewahrt ist, auch in diesem anderen verrückten Land. Und.
Sagt er in der grundsätzliche Unterschied ist in Europa, darfst du prinzipiell Daten von anderen Leuten nicht verarbeiten,
Es sei denn, du kannst es rechtfertigen. Hast deine ähm Einverständnis zu. Imprivate schielt, ist es genau andersrum. Du darfst prinzipiell von allen Leuten alle Daten verarbeiten.
Ähm das heißt, dieses Verbotsprinzip, dass es in Europa gibt, gibt es im Privacy Schield nicht. Das heißt, in der Praxis sagt Max, dass ein Unternehmen eigentlich machen kann, was es will.
Zweiter Punkt in Europa ist, du hast eine Zweckbindung, auf die sehr stark geachtet wird. Du musst deine ähm das kennt man auch immer, wenn man irgendwie so das, was der Text, den man durchstreicht und das Kreuz wegmachen muss. Ich bin damit einverstanden, dass meine Daten zum Zwecke der,
das Bamming und der Werbung und Marketing und so weiter gespeichert werden. Da hat man dann einen Zweck zugestimmt.
Und die Daten dürfen dann nur zu diesem Zweck verwendet werden und zu keinem anderen.
Und ähm äh das Beispiel, was Max nennt, ist der Arzt darf die Krankenakte nicht für äh für Marketing verwenden. Er darf der denn nicht irgendwie sagen, komm hier äh ich schicke dir mal Werbung für Dialyse oder sowas, ne? Wir haben ein neues Dialyseangebot bei uns.
Drücken, hier tolle neue Krücken für meine Kniepatienten und so. Internet.
Im Imprivacy schied ist die so generisch, dass man einen so breiten Zweck definieren kann.
Dass man dann wiederum mit den Daten machen kann, was man will,
Das sind also die zentralen Punkte und da das klingt hier wie Details, aber sind natürlich immer so Dinge, die dann,
vollständig öffnen, ne?
Also wenn wenn das gesamte, wenn das gesamte Abkommen, die gesamten gesamten Gesetze sind, das darfst du, das darfst du nicht, das darfst du nur nach Einwilligung und Einwilligung braucht man nicht und und Zweck kann irgendwie so breit wie man will definiert werden, dann kann's da drunter dahinter noch hunderte von Seitentext schreiben, äh und irgendwelche Details regeln, wenn quasi die Anfangsprämissen nicht
gegeben sind, dann ähm ist schlecht. Ja, also da werden wir jetzt sehen, wie es mit dem Privacy schielt, dann,
weitergehen wird.
Schönes Beispiel für so Bassword äh basierte Politik. So.
Das einzige Privace Schied, was wir haben, ist Adonymisierungsdienste und Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung. Das ist das Privacy Shielt. Alles andere haben wir nicht. Leider, leider, leider, leider.
Es wäre sehr schön natürlich, wenn.
Deutsche Bundesverfassungsgericht würde ich mit mit Einschränkung da auch doch mit reinnehmen mit Einschränkung.
Ja, weil er halt echt langsames Privacy fielt, ne.
Ja, das ist auch hier wieder so ein bisschen der der Tenor für meinen Geschmack, so nach dem Motto, ach, geht nicht. Dann benennen wir das jetzt einfach mal um, dasselbe in grün,
und dann wird das eben auch so auf so Regierungsebene in Anführungsstrichen, weil Kommission, Regierung ist ja nochmal was anderes
aber im Prinzip sind das halt auch alles mal wieder so Dinge am Parlament vorbei
Man merkt ja auch irgendwie den Druck und würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das einfach auch viel mit diesen hängenden CETA und Tippverhandlungen zu tun hat, dass man einfach hier versucht, Command Ground zu schaffen
ohne den halt auch diese ganzen Vereinbarungen nicht nicht denkbar sind, zumal die ja nun ohnehin,
durch das potenzielle Ausscheiden von Britannien eh nochmal wahrscheinlich komplett neu gedacht werden müssen.
Also vielleicht auch nicht, aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine schwerwiegende Änderung der äh der Gesamtsituation, die ja der.
Die hier verhindert wird.
Die auch überhaupt nicht abschätzbar ist, ne? Aber ich will jetzt keine Brexit-Diskussion vom Zaun brechen.
Können wir aber gerne machen, Tim. Wie äh wie lange dulden wir dich hier eigentlich noch? Mal gucken. Hast du, hast du jetzt eigentlich Einbürgerung schon beantragt? Wie viele Bundesländer hat Deutschland? Hä?
Und äh wie heißen die?
Wir.
Jetzt kannst du angeben, weil Tim müsst müssten, müssten die Hörer ja wissen, die Hörer und Hörerin. Tim kennt von allen deutschen Bundesländern die Hauptstädte. Schleswig-Holstein.
Kiel.
Siehst du? Weißt du?
Darf ich bleiben.
Also wenn du dich, wenn du an dich hältst und dem, der dem Sachbearbeiter in der Behörde nicht seine eigenen Grammatikfehler ankreidest.
Dann könnte es sein, dass du damit durchkommst.
Zu Aldi.
Ja, man muss sich schon zurückhalten. Das ist nicht einfach.
Der niedersächsische Genitiv lauert hinter jeder Ecke äh muss ich nochmal meinen meinen Drummer schielt irgendwie hochhalten.
Diese diesen komischen Witz kennst du doch, oder? Was ich ein ein deutscher Mitbürger fragt, ein Zuwanderer, äh.
Dies kommt der Aldiwitz, ja, den kenne ich. Ich kenne das alles. Okay. Ich bin ja aus.
Kennst du alte Witze? Okay. Super, dann müssten jetzt die.
Aus Deutschland mein Freund.
Die ich kenne, muss jetzt den Aldi-Sitzkugeln.
Ich war einfach bisher über EU-Bürger, ich plane auch das äh weiterhin zu bleiben. Das musste ich jetzt halt äh zeigen, welche Maßnahmen dafür erforderlich sind, so, aber,
mir ist diese ganze Nation in unterscheiderei schon immer sehr fremd gewesen. Fuck you.
Ja, oh, vorsicht,
ist nicht Deutsch. Das ist nicht Deutsch und das schließt sofort durch.
Kommen wir, wo wir schon gerade in Baden-Württemberg sind, ähm Bayern.
München ist einfach. Nein, ich wollte jetzt.
Nein, ich wollte jetzt was sagen. Bayer in Bayern.
In Bayern hat der Verfassungsschutz jetzt Zugriff auf die durch die Vorratsdatenspeicherung erlangten Daten,
Er braucht allerdings, ne? In Bayern ist ja auch der wird der Rechtsstaat ja hochgehalten. Deswegen braucht der Verfassungsschutz eine Zustimmung der G zehn Kommission des bayrischen Landtags
um Zugriff auf die Vorratsdaten zu erlangen. Beschert hat uns diese äh dieses schöne Gesetz, die ähm,
die CSU mitgegenstimmen von SPD,
Bündnis neunzig die Grünen und den äh Oso und die freien Wähler haben sich enthalten.
Es gibt ja noch weitere lustige Nachrichten. Das sind jetzt lustig lustige Nachrichten. Heute, jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt eine lustige Nachricht.
Jetzt kommt der Unterhaltungsteil.
Also, wer schon mal im Internet ähm was bezahlen wollte.
Der wird bei einigen äh Anbietern äh über eine sehr elaborierte ähm Fishing-Methode gestolpert sein, die sich,
Sofort Überweisungen nennt. Ähm das heißt du bist also du du möchtest was bezahlen jetzt hier äh hast du was bestellt oder so, ne? Und dann äh sagen die Witz, wie willst du denn bezahlen? Und,
dann wird dir die Zahlungsmethode sofort Überweisung angeboten.
Hoffentlich unter anderem.
Hoffentlich unter anderem und hoffentlich klickst du da nicht drauf,
Äh wer das mal macht und denkt so, ach sofort Überweisung, was ist das? Den klicke ich mal drauf. Der landet dann auf einer äh Fishing-Seite, die äh ja, Entschuldigung ist so.
Äh ja, Entschuldigung, ist so.
Dich bittet, die den Nutzer bittet doch seine äh Online-Banking-Zugangsdaten diesem dritten Anbieter mitzuteilen,
Also du gibst dann der sofort GmbH,
die jetzt GmbH weiß ja, ne? Fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro, ein Lager, ist eine GmbH. Denen vertraust du dann deine Online-Banking-Zugangsdaten an.
Und mit diesen Zugangsdaten können sie ja ähm zumindest schon mal auf deinen Kontostand zugreifen und die eine Transaktionsnummer, die du ihnen gibst, damit können sie eine Transaktion durchführen,
Im Zweifelsfall dann bisher diejenige, um äh die du sie auch gebeten hast.
Bisher. Also wir haben keine Kenntnis davon, dass andere äh Transaktionen durchgeführt wurden wären bisher bisher, um das gleich mal dazu zu sagen. Oder hast du solche Erkenntnisse? Ich habe solche Erkenntni.
Ich habe das nicht, ich würde das aber auch nicht riskieren, denn es ist grundsätzlich eine äußerst äußerst äußerst äußerst schlechte Idee einer dritten Partei Zugangsdaten zu etwas zu geben,
dass man selber gerne hat und äh viele Leute haben ja ihr eigenes Geld sehr gerne
Und deswegen steht auch in den AGBs der Banken drin, die Zugangsdaten, Transaktionsnummern, gibst du niemand anders,
Weil wenn du das tust, dann ist schlecht, dann haben die nämlich Zugriff auf deine auf dein Onlinebanking-Konto und können damit machen, was sie wollen.
So ist es sinnvoll, es in die AGBs reinzuschreiben, wenn man irgendein,
wenn man irgendein Vertrauen in seine Kunden aufrecht erhalten möchte, dass sie einen verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit den Online-Banking-Zugangsdaten pflegen.
Und die Sofort GmbH sah durch diesen Passus in den AGB ihr ähm ihr.
Ich will's jetzt nicht Geschäftsmodell nennen in Gefahr und hat sich beschwert beim Bundeskartellamt
und hat gesagt äh wir haben hier Top-Geschäftsidee, wir nehmen einfach die Zugangsdaten von den Leuten, loggen uns für die bei ihrem Onlinebanking ein, sammeln die Zugangsdaten, nennen das Ganze Sofortüberweisung und sind voll cool,
Und dann kassieren wir von den Anbietern, für die wir das äh für die wir diese einfache äh Möglichkeit der Zahlung äh durchsetzen. Natürlich eine Provision und dann sind wir reich,
Und dummerweise steht unserem unserem ich ja unserem Geschäftsmodell will ich jetzt echt nicht sagen, aber unserem unserer Masche,
im Wege, dass diese gemeinen Banken den Leuten vorschreiben, sie dürfen die Zugangsdaten niemand anders geben.
Und dann sagt das Bundeskartellamt. Äh wie zeigt mir das? Kann ja nicht sein. Ja, es geht ja nun echt nicht,
Die Online-Banking-Bedingungen der deutschen Kreditwirtschaft führen zu einer Behinderung von neuen und innovativen Dienstleistungsangeboten.
Auf den erwachsenen Ma.
Auf dem wachsenden Markt für Bezahlverfahren im Internet handeln. So dann der Behördenchef Andreas Mund am vergangenen Dienstag.
Ich glaube, da ist mal wieder eine eine neue Stelle äh frei geworden.
Möchte ich zu uns mein Chef vom Bundeskartellamt werden. Ich glaube, hier hat sich jemand gerade disqualifiziert.
Hier hat echt einer Fieber.
Ja, also es ist wirklich bemerkenswert. Also man das das schöne Wort finde ich an dieser Stelle innovativ. Und ich würde sogar sagen,
dass in Bezug auf Sofortüberweisung, auf diese, heißt ja offiziell Sofort GmbH,
also eine gewisse Innovation möchte ich Ihnen jetzt noch gar nicht mal absprechen, weil sie sich ja sozusagen in einem in Erstarrung gefangenen Bankensystem versuchen, in irgendeiner Form,
zwischen die Händler zu klemmen und verschiedene Unternehmen haben ja da verschiedene Ideen,
wie man solche Bezahlwege vermitteln kann, aber das große Problem ist, dass halt einfach mal,
dem am weitesten, verbreiteten äh Kontosystem, nämlich unser Bankensystem, wo,
Seepaar Transaktionen möglich sind. Mit kostenlosen,
Überweisung und was ja nun hier auch schon digital seid, ich weiß nicht seit seit den frühen Achtziger Jahren,
Seit es bitte X gibt, ist sozusagen Online-Banking eine eine Realität und das war ja sagen wir mal im Vergleich zu Zettel an der Filiale abgeben. Äh ein ein Riesenschritt. Nur,
die Einfachheit einer PayPal-Transaktion, nämlich klick hier, log dich ein, schick das Geld, fertig ist die Laube.
Haben die Banken ja bis zum Jahr zwanzig sechzehn nicht hinbekommen. Es gibt ja sozusagen kein Angebot, was das einfach macht. Wenn ich heute online was kaufe, dann geht das halt,
relativ einfach mit Kreditkartennummern, was aber auch äh aus Sicherheitsgründen sehr problematisch ist, weil man ja in der Regel dem Händler mehr oder weniger alle Daten äh des eigenen,
Zahlungszugangs gibt, ne? Also im Prinzip ist ja auch das Übermitteln einer Kreditkartennummer plus Sicherheitscode,
versetzt ja auch jeden Händler in die Lage zehn Minuten später bei mir irgendwas abzubuchen,
Also insofern ist jetzt diese Sofort GmbH noch noch nicht mal äh äh
viel schlimmer aufgestellt, nur dass sie natürlich äh die die Sicherheitsmethodik des gesamten Onlinebankingsystems in in Deutschland äh im Prinzip.
Und unterwandert.
Gegen eine unberechtigte Einziehung von deinem Konto hast du, glaube ich, sechs Wochen Widerspruchsmöglichkeit.
Ja, man kann das.
Eine Sofortüberweisung hast du gar keine Möglichkeit vor.
Ach so, ja genau, wenn das, wenn das eine Lastschriftzahlung ist, dann dann kann man das sozusagen sofort rückgängig machen bei einer eigenen Überweisung, bin ich mir eben nicht so sicher, da läuft das sicherlich ein bisschen anders. Genau, das ist auch nochmal ein Problem, habe ich noch gar nicht drüber nachgedacht,
Was ich nur sagen möchte ist, hier,
kämpft halt auch eine Branche, die eigentlich das Wort Innovation irgendwie noch nicht gehört hat. Also wie lange denken die sich schon immer wieder neue Payment-Systeme aus, die komplett scheitern,
Mit ihrer wie hieß dieses Bargeldsystem auf den auf den Chips? Was keiner benutzt,
Geldkarte und der ganze Mumpels und so weiter, ne.
Quatsch.
Genau, ne? Und es ist halt auch sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig das zu machen. Und insofern ist jetzt diese Sofort, ich will das jetzt gar nicht schönreden. Ich sage nur so war halt an der Stelle die die Logik, die sie getrieben hat. Ja, also die einfachste Methode ist sozusagen, wir bauen dieses Online-Banking
quasi so zentral in der Cloud und die Leute äh
müssen halt uns nur die Zugangsdaten geben, dann dann kriegen wir diese Kommunikation schon hin, ne, aber dass man mal halt irgendeinen Standard äh etabliert wie eine Bank sich gegenüber
The Payments äh verhält, umstandardisiert, solche Überweisungen äh auszurufen, ja? Das hätten die Banken ja auch selber machen können.
Das hätten die Banken selber machen können und die die Banken, ich fahre vor vor zwei Jahren oder so mal irgendwie.
Auf so einem Finanzkongress
ähm wo in Frankfurt. Und da habe ich denen auch gesagt, so Freunde, schaut mal an, wenn ich heute im Internet bezahlen möchte, ne. Dann,
kann ich das hier über PayPal machen, das ist eigentlich ganz angenehm, weil ich muss ja nur meine E-Mail-Adresse angeben und ein Passwort. Und natürlich äh Sicherheit hin oder her, ne? Und irgendwie Zensur der Zahlung und so alles äh,
Alles ein Ding dort, aber,
Die machen es mir einfach und in der gleichen Zeit, wo PayPal von irgendwie, weiß, wann haben die angefangen, irgendwann zweitausender,
Wahrscheinlich frühe zweitausender Jahre. Äh in der gleichen Zeit, wo PayPal so reich geworden ist, dass die Eigner äh inzwischen irgendwie,
Tesla bauen und und irgendwelche komischen Hyperloops und und äh selbst zurückkommende Raketen. In der Zeit habt ihr
Sepa System eingeführt, wo du jetzt eine IBAN hast, die
keine Sau sich mehr merken kann. Die armen Omas stehen jetzt mit ihren Überweisungsträgern da und überweist die ganze Zeit Geld irgendwo anders hin, weiß ich nicht, weil sie sich diese scheiß Nummern nicht merken können, ja?
Ihr seid nicht auf die Idee gekommen, da irgendwas mal, also mal irgendwas zu machen, das kann doch nicht ernsthaft sein, wo in einer Welt, in der Menschen inzwischen mit ihrer hier, mit so einer Uhr, wie du da am Armand hast, ihr ihr Geld äh äh ausgeben können,
Ähm sitzt ihr da und sagt, jo geil, äh hier ist deine neue IBAN, ja. Er ist doch nun wirklich ähm peinlich.
Es ist es ist wirklich.
War ihnen dann auch peinlich, war er in der Nos selber peinlich und dann sagten sie jetzt, ja Scheiß, aber wir müssen da da hängt halt Unmengen an Regulierungs äh Dingen hinter,
Also hinter ihrem Bankenbetrieb da, ne? Kriegen halt haben,
Unerhörte Regulierungsaufgaben und so weiter und dann diese, sie haben auch zum Beispiel Verpflichtungen, dass so eine Seepaar-Überweisung muss, glaube ich, innerhalb von einem Tag abgewickelt sein und so, das war früher nicht so und so weiter. Also die haben da richtig,
Infrastrukturelle Änderungen,
betrieben und werden von vorne bis hinten durchreguliert. Zurecht, weil wenn du denen auch nur irgendwie den Hauch einer Lücke lässt, ruinieren, sehr direkt die gesamte Weltwirtschaft,
habe ich dann auch kurz angemerkt, ja, dass ich das durchaus ganz in Ordnung finde, wenn man da durchaus vielleicht mal reguliert, bei denen,
Aber die, die sind tatsächlich am am bitterlich weinen, dass dann so eine Sofortüberweisungs GmbH daherkommt mit äh relativ geringen äh Regulierungsauflagen. Ähm,
und ihn da.
Halt was wegnimmt, ne? Gewisse Banken haben auch den, die wollen ja dieses Privatkundengeschäft auch gar nicht mehr haben,
Gewisse Banken haben offenbar gar keinen Bock mehr da drauf. Ähm vor allem in Zeiten der ähm,
Dieser nigelniedrigen Zinsen und der Negativzinsen, die es jetzt gibt, haben die Banken eigentlich überhaupt gar keinen Bock, die Geldspeicher für die Leute zu sein,
und haben auch keinen Bock auf diese Kleckerbezahlsachen, ne? Da gibt's also durchaus Banken, die gesagt haben, komm, damit wollen wir gar nichts zu tun haben eigentlich. Aber.
Das innovative Konzept,
Sehe ich jetzt bei dieser Sofortüberweisungsnummer nun wirklich nicht. Also das geht echt nicht klar. Und die ähm gleichzeitig ist es halt ein Drama, dass die Banken,
Es nicht selber in all den Jahren, in den, in den zwei Jahrzehnten,
hingekriegt haben, einen halbwegs vernünftigen Standard auf die Beine zu kriegen. Und die machen's immer wieder neu und immer wieder Kacke und immer benutzt das keiner. Wie viele Anläufe haben die jetzt schon durch,
Geldkarte, was ein Scheiß. Was ein Scheiß hast du das mal gemacht? Ich glaube, ich habe sogar in meinem Leben aus Versehen mal fünf Euro auf so eine Geldkarte getan. Die waren weg. Konzerniere die Ecke, was soll ich damit machen? Konntest du Zigaretten mitholen? Mache ich nicht.
So, dann hast du da dann hast du fünf Euro auf diesem Chip und kriegst die ja nicht wieder runter. Katastrophe. Hast du Karte verloren? War das Geld weg.
Ja, denn dieser Wildwuchs an an Zahlsystemen und und Benahmsungen, ich meine, kein Mensch, wenn du halt dann ein äh Bankautomaten gehst und dann diese Myriaden an,
Karten, Logos siehst, weißt du überhaupt nicht mehr, was Sache ist. Ja, was habe ich denn jetzt? Habe ich jetzt Giropee oder habe ich jetzt Maistro oder heißt es nicht doch irgendwie EC, dann heißt es so, dann heißt es so
direkt hier Payda, keiner blickt auch nur ansatzweise irgendwie durch. Ich glaub das einzige was zumindest in Deutschland halbwegs verstanden wurde ist Teil was von deiner Karte,
Von deiner Bank bekommst ist wahrscheinlich eine EC-Karte, ist es ja dann auch nicht unbedingt immer, dann heißt es dann Kundenkarte, dann sind's teilweise irgendwie Kreditkarten, die sind aber.
Visitenkarte.
Die die sind aber dann auch eigentlich keine Kreditkarten, weil du kriegst da keinen Kredit, sondern das ist eine Debatte, so nennt das aber hier irgendwie keiner, da wird aber auch noch nicht groß unterschieden
Mit dem einen mit der einen Karte hast du folgende Zahlmöglichkeit, mit der anderen hast du folgendes, ist es ein totaler Wahnsinn und es ist vollkommen unerklärlich
warum es denen nicht gelungen ist, gerade auch im Zuge mit Seepaar. Also wo sie wo sie gerade mal gelungen ist, irgendwie eine andere Schreibung derselben Zahlen,
hinzubekommen, die dann noch nicht mal davon,
entbindet alles nochmal doppelt anzugeben, weil wenn ich jetzt außerhalb von Deutschland irgendwo eine Überweisung jetzt Seepaar mache, dann muss ich trotzdem noch diesen Bankcode angeben, also noch mehr Zahlen mit noch mehr die Big, genau.
Der aber eigentlich ja sich aus der aus der Swift, aus der IBAN.
Errechnen sollte, wenn es eine deutsche Nummer ist, aber dann halt nicht in den anderen Ländern, also du hast sozusagen einen riesen, dicken Fuß, dann wollen sie auch immer noch die Adresse von der Bank, wo du hinweist, also wo leben wir denn? Ja, soll ich noch die Post kutschen nochmal noch mit dazu schreiben? Ist vollkommen
absurd und da und da und und sie schaffen's einfach, ich meine, die haben ja noch nicht mal, es gibt ja noch nicht mal eine URL,
Spezifikationen, wo ich mal draufklicke, damit sich irgendwie eine standardisierte Homebanking-App startet. Das wäre ja schon mal ein Schritt gewesen.
Die haben's ja noch nicht mal hingekriegt, dieses ähm diese IBAN IDNTV, die waren ja also,
so die schöne Theorie, das ist ja immerhin eine Vereinheitlichung, dann hast du ja gibt's ja irgendwie die,
Bankleitzahl mit äh mit Nullen davor, wenn die zu kurz ist, äh Kontonummer und so weiter und dann haben sie ja das einzige, was wirklich gut ist an diesem IBON-Ding ist,
eine Prüfsumme hinten, ne? Zwei äh zwei oder eine ähm ein Inter am Ende und,
Natürlich kann man ja mal so eine IBAN angucken. Nee, ich habe gerade keinen IBAN doch.
Zwei vorne, ne?
Was weiß ich. Haben wir auf jeden Fall eine Prüfsumme drin. Das heißt, wenn du einen Zahlendreher hast, sollte das System sofort erkennen, dass es sich nicht um eine äh gültige IBAN handelt, dann kann dir deine Onlinebanking-App schon bevor du das überhaupt der Bank schickst sagen,
nicht, was du hier vorhast. Da musst du nochmal nachgucken,
Das ist das einzig Gute und damit schützen sie wahrscheinlich auch die ganzen armen Leute, die noch Handüberweisungen ausführen, der jetzt diese langen äh Dinger eintippen müssen äh vor allerlei ungemach, ähm aber.
Es ist wirklich ein Drama. Nur so wie das hier diese Sofortüberweisung.
Vollkommen absurd, deutsche IBAN zweiundzwanzig stellen, österreichische IBAN zwanzig Stellen, Schweizer Iban, einundzwanzig Cent. Leute, wirklich.
Ja
Ähm aber wie gesagt, die Banken, wenn du dich da mit so Banken drüber unterhältst, die sagen dir dann ja, wir hätten uns das auch schöner vorstellen können, aber ähm das hat äh gleichzeitig eine Menge Probleme, die sie in
in Haushalten mit ihrem Clearing und so weiter. Tatsächlich vereinfacht und einige Banken da da unterscheiden sich aber die Banken sagen, ihr müsst doch super äh die Leute sollen da regelmäßige Geldeingänge drauf haben und uns ist doch scheißegal, wie die ihr Geld da wieder runterkriegen
aber andere Banken sehen das eben auch genau anders.
Fakt ist, dieser Zahlzahlungsdienstleistermarkt ist signifikant. Die ähm,
Kreditkarten kassieren, Prozente vom Umsatz. Ja, also das sind echt äh richtige Geld,
äh Anlagen und denen ein bisschen was wegzunehmen durch
so kontaktlose Zahlungsmöglichkeiten oder überhaupt deine eine einfache Zahlungsmöglichkeit ist sowas von attraktiv, dass er inzwischen Apple aus dem Stand das macht
und seine eigenen Standards da definiert, nicht ganz definiert, die haben ja also zumindest ihre eigene Plattform definiert, Standards nutzen sie ja vorhanden, ne?
Ähm aber jetzt äh Zahlungsdienst, Zahlungsanbieter zu werden, ist für alle interessant und es ist für mich absolut nicht nachvollziehbar, dass die,
am Markt existierenden Platz hierschen ähm.
Es in Jahrzehnten nicht geschafft haben, da die Innovation mit zu ähm zu gestalten.
Ja und jetzt passt das Kartellamt natürlich auch nicht unbedingt einfacher. Wenn jetzt sozusagen.
Wenn sie jetzt also das ist der Untergang.
Auch noch auch noch ja vor allem das ist auch auf so vielen Ebenen falsch, man paar mal ja schon äh gesagt so du sollst niemals geheime Daten rausgeben, weil das ist der Sinn, warum sie geheim sind,
ja? Äh.
Auch der auch die Kultur, die damit befördert wird, ja? Also ich meine, wenn die Leute sozusagen gewohnt sind,
Du klickst irgendwo im Internet auf bezahlen
und dann sind das die Daten, die du da eingibst, wie soll man den Leuten denn überhaupt noch klar machen, dass sie das Passwatter etwas Privates äh äh sind und äh das geht einfach überhaupt nicht.
Es ist zu mollen.
Wissen sie dagegen? Wir wollen möglichst kein Geld ausgeben müssen und alles für alle. Umsonst.
Zumindest für uns.
Ich bin ja froh.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ist nicht so einfach, hier mit dem ganzen äh Cyber äh in der neuen Zeit.
Der Cyber lauert überall.
Dauert überall, da muss auch mal an der Sicherheit gearbeitet werden, passiert da eigentlich was.
Ja klar, da gibt's jetzt ähm,
Gibt's jetzt eine neue Cyber-Sicherheitsstrategie? Die letzte, die letzte hat, glaube ich, fünf Jahre gehalten. Äh äh.
So lang. Immerhin.
Und zwar wurde jetzt die Cybersicherheitsstrategie für Deutschland zwanzig sechzehn herabgereicht. Äh beziehungsweise noch nicht herabgereicht. Es ist, die ist im Moment noch vertraulich äh und liegt deshalb auch nur äh dem äh,
Im Spiegel glaube ich vor und im Deutschlandradio oder sowas, also zwei ähm Medien,
Nee, Quatsch. Ähm Zeit oder wem lag das vor.
Spiegel und Zeit.
Ja, aber der Link, den du da jetzt gerade bezeichnest, ist es nicht, das ist ein falscher Link. Nee, doch, ist ein richtiger Link. Ähm,
Zeit hatte, hat es vorliegend und hat sich da jetzt mal ein bisschen mit auseinandergesetzt. So und zwar möchte das Innenministerium jetzt ähm.
Die deutsche Cyberabwehr auf äh drei Säulen stellen. Ja? Deutschlandfunk und Zeit online haben dieses vertrauliche Papier vorliegen. Und zwar ist es hauptsächlich so, du hast ähm.
In Deutschland ja das äh BSI, Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik und dann als Ergebnis der letzten Cyber-Sicherheitsstrategie. Ähm, dass Cyberabwärtzentrum,
Ähm ich suche das mal gerade,
So, das Cyberabwärtszentrum, genau zweitausendelf vor fünf Jahren wurde das mit der Cyberabwehr Cybersicherheitsstrategie ähm der Bundesregierung.
Gegründet und drei Jahre später äh urteilte dann der Bundesrechnungshof, dass es nahezu nutzlos sei, weil es von keiner der beteiligten Behörden ernst genommen wird. Das äh Cyber ähm Abwehrzentrum,
und ähm,
Jetzt möchten sie das ändern ähm und möchten das dem Abwehrzentrum ähm mit, dass das existierende Cyber-Abwehrzentrum mehr Geld und Einfluss versorgen.
Und.
Da das soll es mit einer mit der Aufgabenbeschreibung das Wissen über Angriffe zu verteilen.
Und auch die Bundeswehr und ihre Cybertruppen mit einzubeziehen,
Wie genau ist bisher unklar? Was heißt, es wird eine zivilmilitärische Zusammenarbeit zwischen dem Abwehrzentrum und der Bundeswehr geben. Die aber noch neu konzipiert werden soll. Also wir haben BSI,
Wir haben Abwehrzentrum mit Schnittstelle zur Bundeswehr und wir bekommen.
Ein Computer Emergency Response Team, ein Zert. Ähm,
Das bestehen soll aus Fachleuten, die möglichst schnell Probleme analysieren und lösen. Einen Surt hast du ähm teilweise auch in in Unternehmen, aber teilweise auch in,
Ländern. Äh in äh ja in Ländern. Ähm da hast du dann also eine quasi eine.
Notfall Cybernotfallhilfe. Könnte man das quasi nennen, ne? Ähm.
Ja und die äh die drei möchte man also haben, das heißt, es die Aufgabenteilung soll sein.
Abwehrzentrum Lagezentrum.
Also du du wendest dich an das Zert, wenn du angegriffen wirst, das wird dann die Abwehr des Angriffs leiten,
Dafür ist das Zert, ne? Emergency. Das BSI wird die Methoden und Instrumente der Angreifer analysieren und daraus eine technische Beratung,
ableiten
für die Zukunft. Das heißt äh in, dass dieses Eingreifervorgehen in zukünftige Standards oder so einfließen lassen oder eben nicht, wie sie es in der Regel machen und
dass Cyber-Abwehrzentrum solle dann alle staatlichen Behörden miteinander verbinden. Angefangen vom BSI,
Über Bundeswehr, über Polizei und Geheimdienste und Zoll. Ähm das soll dann das BSI machen.
Was könnte fällt dir irgendwas ein, was da schiefgehen könnte.
Das BSI, wenn das jetzt wieder mit Geheimdiensten und Bundeswehr zusammenarbeitet,
Ja, da kann man sich natürlich vorstellen, wohin die Richtung geht. Äh Polizeien wissen wir ja auch, äh dass das BKA eben das Auge darauf wirft, sich äh Zero Days zu kaufen,
und äh aktive Angriffe zu machen, das heißt ein genuines Interesse an,
Schlechtere IT-Sicherheit hat ebenso wie die Geheimdienste, wir werden bald wieder Staatstrojaner haben, die zu
um in umangebracht werden zu können auf Sicherheitslücken angewiesen sind,
Das wisst über diese Sicherheitslücken möchten die Geheimdienste und die Polizeien natürlich haben, um ihre Staatstrojane anzubringen. Dem sollte eigentlich das BSI entgegenstehen, tut es aber nicht, weil es hat ja schon mal freundliche Hilfe geleistet, den,
Kommunikation, die Command Control, Kommunikation des Staatstrojaners äh mit einer vernünftigen Krypto auszustatten und damit
seinem Dienst am Bürger äh nachzukommen, wie sie meinten und.
Ja
Man will eigentlich nicht, dass die zusammenarbeiten. Aber wo wir gerade schon mal den Bericht des Bundesrechnungshofs über das Cyber-Abwehrzentrum zitiert haben, können wir genauso nochmal kurz den Bericht des Bundesrechnungshofes,
Die Bundeswehr zu äh zu in Betracht ziehen, der wurde nämlich äh bei Spiegel Online,
veröffentlicht am und das ist ein Bericht von zweiundzwanzigsten Juni, also druckfrisch wo Sie sagen die Bundeswehr sichere den Zugang zu sensiblen Daten,
nicht ausreichend und das lege größtenteils daran, dass die Firma BWI.
Ein Joint Venture äh der Bundeswehr mit der Industrie. Äh Nachfolger des Bundeswehrprojektes Herkules. Ähm,
als alleiniger Kommunikationsprovider der Truppe arbeitet. Das heißt, die Bundeswehr hat ihren IT-Betrieb äh,
an ein Monopolanbieter, das ist eine sehr gute Idee und ähm entsprechend trägt diese sehr gute Idee jetzt auch Früchte.
Denn ähm es wird erstens vom Bundesrechnungshof angemerkt, dass es,
Für den Bundesrechnungshof nicht verständlich ist, dass die Bundeswehr die Vertraulichkeit und Integrität ihrer durch die BWI verwalteten Daten nicht kontrolliere. Es gibt keine Checks,
wer als Systemadministrator der BWI Zugriff auf vertrauliche Kommunikation wie zum Beispiel Personal oder Finanzdaten der Truppe hätte,
Das heißt ähm das ist im Prinzip so eine Snowden Situation, ne? Also die haben ihren die haben irgendwelche privatwirtschaftlichen Administratoren, die da Zugriff auf alles haben. Ähm wenn du Glück hast, ist da ein Snowden dabei, der ähm,
Das Ganze an die Öffentlichkeit trägt und äh die Verletzung von Bürgerrechten anprangert. Äh wenn du Pech hast, ist da äh jemand anderes dabei. Äh der da in der freien Wirtschaft.
Einen Admin Job hat ähm.
Insgesamt einhundertvierzigtausend Bundeswehrcomputer sind da in der Hoheit dieser äh BWI und die bei Stichproben haben diese Bundesrechnungshofprüfer eben festgestellt, dass die,
Zugriffsrechte auf ein Teilsystem des Bundeswehrnetzes, über das die Truppe rund,
Millionen, für das die Truppe rund acht Millionen Euro pro Jahr auszahlt, nicht ein einziges Mal kontrolliert wurden, also zahlst acht Millionen an deinen Dienstleister, da wird nicht ein nicht einmal die Zugriffsrechte,
kontrolliert, äh, entsprechend ist es da wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz fürchterlich, ja?
Prüfung gab es, muss man dazu sagen, aber auch vor allem nur deshalb, weil eine Übernahme dieser Firma durch die Bundeswehr geplant ist, Ende dieses Jahres.
Ja, damit darf das wäre zu hoffen, ja,
aber nicht nur die Sicherheit dieser Firma äh kritisieren die Prüfer, sie bemängeln außerdem, dass die Bundeswehr bisher viel mehr Geld an diese BWI äh bezahlt habe, weil's als vertraglich vereinbart war
und sie fordern das Verteidigungsministerium dringend auf mindestens einhundertvierundzwanzig Millionen Euro zurückzufordern,
Dann kannst du mal überlegen, was was dir wahrscheinlich insgesamt eingezahlt haben.
Ähm ein bisschen Kritik gibt's auch äh an der Vergütung des BWI Chefs,
Denn der äh ist ein früherer T-Systemsmanager, den sie dort hingesetzt haben und die Vergütung wird als durchaus ungewöhnlich,
bezeichnet, da er inklusive Boni auf eine halbe Million Euro,
Jahresgehalt plus Dienstwagen gekommen ist und eine ganz angenehme Abfindung für den Fall einer Kündigung zugesichert hat ähm in der Wirtschaft sei sowas vielleicht äh normal, aber im Mysterium,
bekommt niemand so viel Geld.
Und bestimmt auch keine Abfindung.
Sicherlich auch keine Abfindung, wobei ich weiß nicht, ob man vielleicht, wenn du bei der Bundeswehr äh den frühen Ausscheiden zugeführt wirst, da kriegst du ja sicherlich irgendwie so eine Art Lebensversicherungsabfindung, Witwenrente oder sowas.
Ja, das geht bei. Ja, also Rennrentenansprüche sind sicherlich nennenswer.
Rentenansprüche sind da ja, aber.
Da darüber ist das dann eher wird das abgewickelt, aber ist nicht.
Frühzeitiges Ausscheiden aus der Truppe ist glaube ich nicht so einfach möglich. Du verpflichtest dich doch da irgendwie.
Ja und wenn du aus irgendwelchen Gründen halt lassen.
Gesundheitliche Gründe.
Jetzt nicht irgendwie dann nochmal eine Million hintern geschoben.
Ja, kommt drauf an, in welchem Gefecht du dann äh unter äh.
Mutmaßen schon wieder.
Ja, aber super, das heißt, da läuft's echt prima.
Ist ja auch ein Topthema, ne? Also äh Cyber ist großen Com. Da kann man echt erstmal.
Und also da haben wir, da können wir echt jetzt mal eine neue Strategie entwickeln, wie man damit umgeht.
Ich versuche mir da sowas immer äh dadurch vorzustellen, wenn man das so über über äh übertragen würde auf Zugang zur Waffenkammer.
Ja, also wenn man sozusagen dieselben Kontrollparadigmen, die jetzt hier im Digitalbereich vorherrschen,
quasi mit Gebäudezugang oder Waffenkammerzugang vergleicht,
ja? Also der hat sich noch nie mal einer angeschaut wie man denn eigentlich in diese Gebäude reinkommt. Und wer da überhaupt reingehen darf,
Und für welcher, welcher Aufwand sozusagen von Nöten wäre. Ist eigentlich merkwürdig, dass man würde ja nun eigentlich vermuten,
dass Leute, die so im Militär sind, die ja so eine Grund.
Wie soll ich sagen, schon so ein gewisses Grundmisstrauen eigentlich geschult bekommen,
ich war lieber Meditär, deswegen kann ich da nicht zu kompetent mich zu äußern, aber wenn ich eine militärische Ausbildung genieße und äh so Dinge wie
Ich sichere meine eigene Position gegenüber einem potenziellen Angreifer, damit ich halt mal nicht eben von irgendeinem Heckenschützen äh umgehauen werde und bevor ich halt irgendein Land betrete, muss ich halt auch gewisse Sicherungsmaßnahmen durchführen, äh was ich sagen will, ist,
die Logik des Sicherens,
die die auch dieses strategische Denken der der Einnahme oder Verteidigung eines bestimmten Ortes müsste ja eigentlich im Militär irgendwie nennenswert verankert sein, aber,
Das scheint mir hier noch nicht so richtig ins äh digitale Zeitalter rübergeholt worden zu sein, zumindest nicht in Deutschland, aber man kann das ja auch verstehen, weil das ist ja eigentlich auch für viele Leute immer noch Neuland.
Tja. Wir bleiben so ein bisschen beim Militär.
Kommen jetzt mal wieder zu einer äh echt ähm nicht so coolen Meldung,
Du siehst, ich mache hier wieder einen Wechsel in der Zeitralleiste. Ähm und zwar ähm hat,
Chelsea Menning, die ja seit die zweitausenddreizehn in neunzehn Punkten schuldig gesprochen ähm,
Zu fünfunddreißig Jahren Freiheitsstrafe verurteilt wurde, weil sie Dokumente äh an Daten und Dokumente an Wiki Leaks weitergegeben hat. Einmal die Cables.
Und die hm also,
Die Botschafts-Depassion und bekannt geworden, vor allem auch die Videoaufnahme des Beschusses und Todes von irakischen Zivilisten durch ein äh Hubschrauber der,
US-Armee. Das äh Video, was als Collateral Mörder bekannt wurde. Ähm Chelsea Meding wurde ja dann damals verraten von,
einem jungen Mann namens Adrian Lemo, auf den ich gleich nochmal kurz eingehen möchte,
Und ähm sitzt seitdem in Florida, in Ford Leven World oder LivenWorf. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht. Ähm,
eben ihre Knaststrafe absitzt,
Und äh die hat jetzt letzte Woche ein ähm Selbstmordversuch unternommen und wurde äh dann in ein Krankenhaus umgelegt.
Das ist natürlich eine aufgefährlich.
Nur um Missverständnisse zu verhindern.
Und äh das ist net, also,
finde ich eine Nachricht über die man echt mal auch nachdenken muss ähm dass diese Person,
Das ist halt eine.
Ähm eine Heldentat, die sie da auch verbracht hat Unmengen an ähm Kriegsverbrechen aufmerksam zu machen,
ähm in den Dokumenten, nur in den Dokumenten, die äh sie weitergegeben hat, finden sich dreihundertunddrei Fälle von Folter durch die Besatzungstruppen im Irak, allein im Jahr zwanzig zehn. Ähm,
ja die hat dafür mit dem mit ihrer mit der Perspektive ihres Lebens bezahlt,
und ähm ist jetzt eben in die Verzweiflung offen an offenbar getrieben worden und hat da einen Selbstmordversuch unternommen, der glücklicherweise ähm missglückt ist,
Und da schließt sich dann auch direkt der Skandal an äh darüber hat zuerst die Presse berichtet, weil irgendeiner vom Militär nicht äh die,
nicht die Schnauze gehalten hat und das eben weitergegeben hat, sodass das an die Presse geliegt, bevor ihre eigenen Anwälte davon erfahren haben,
Das heißt, die Anwälte und Anwältin von Jetsy Melling haben aus der Presse davon erfahren und denen sind ähm.
Irgendwie Situationen vorher passiert, wo sie ihre Mandantin sprechen wollten und dann irgendwie so gesagt, ja die kann grad nicht, äh, tut mir leid, bitte können sie geht gerade nicht. Und dann erfahren sie eben aus der Presse, äh dass sie
verlegt wurde.
Bei der Gelegenheit möchte ich nochmal auf äh Adrian Lemburg zu sprechen kommen. Ich glaube, wir haben den hier schon mal äh gewürdigt, aber ähm ich würde das ganz gerne nochmal machen, damit er auch das nicht in Vergessenheit gerät,
was dieser Mann getan hat, der,
wurde also damals von Chelsea Menning, also es ist ein ein bekannterer ähm Hacker in den USA,
Und äh Chelsea Melling hat sich damals an ihn äh gewendet. Ähm,
Nachdem sie diese Dokumente Wiki Leaks gegeben hat, um jemanden zu haben, mit dem sie sprechen kann. Und der äh.
Im im war das glaube ich, ne?
Genau und irgendeine Chat.
Ja, doch das war ein, das nee, das war Jabba. Das weiß ich sehr genau, weil,
die äh ist eine Einstellung in dem Programm Adium gab, die ähm.
Damals nicht Standard waren, nämlich das OTR-Chats nicht gespeichert werden.
Und das ist aber äh diese Einstellung war nicht Standard und deswegen wurde auch dieses komplette Chatlog zwischen Adrian Lemo und Chelsea Menning gespeichert und konnte dann nachher veröffentlicht werden und auch äh wurde dann auch vor Gericht dann eben
äh debattiert. Und in diesem Chatlot steht eben auch sehr klar drin, wie Adrian Lemom ähm Chelsea Meding sagt, ich bin ein,
Priester,
Und unterliege deshalb der Schweigepflicht und er hat noch eine andere Rolle da beworben. Äh unter der er auch der der Schweigepflicht unterliegen würde und unter dieser Maßgabe äh könne,
sie sich ihm anvertrauen? Letztendlich ist das dann darin gemündet, dass Hedrin Lemo sie ans Messer geliefert hat,
Und dieser Adrian Lemo ähm wie ich dann vor einigen Wochen erfuhr und meinen Augen nicht glauben konnte.
Ist ja immer noch ein frei herumlaufender Mensch,
was mich äh ja, was mich nicht wundert, weil er natürlich unter äh Schutz des äh des FBI und der Regierung steht, der er hier einen großen Gefallen getan hat. Übrigens auch nicht zum ersten Mal und ähm,
Um den gab es jetzt letztens nochmal eine kontroverse, weil er hat Ministrator, der Twenty Six Hunrard Facebook Gruppe war,
Twentysix Hunrard ist ein ähm Hackermagazin, was glaube ich vierteljährlich oder halbjährlich erscheint,
Quartal, ne? Aber er scheint's auch wirklich nur noch vierjährig oder heißt es nur so.
Ich glaube dem.
Halbjährlich.
Weiß ich nicht, ob sich das äh verändert hat, aber das ist sozusagen der ursprüngliche Erscheinungsmodus.
The Twentysix handelt Quarterley und das ist also quasi der würde ich vom wahrscheinlich sagen den,
Eine der den CC-Idealen am nächsten stehenden Gruppierungen in den USA, oder?
Kann man so sagen, es gibt da viele persönliche Bekanntschaften schon seit den achtziger Jahren. Ähm
Dazu muss man aber natürlich sehen, dass die Situation in den USA schon immer ganz anders war für die Hackerszene als in Deutschland, aber Manuel Golz, die eine der Gründer und die mit Abstand sichtbarste Figur in äh dem ganzen Geschehen,
Ist schon seit Ewigkeiten auf CC Events gewesen, also schon in den achtziger Jahren
ganz stark dann auch nochmal in den neunziger und später ist ja ohnehin so ein so ein so ein interessanter Weltreisender auch der permanent unterwegs ist,
Von daher gab's da schon immer äh Beziehungen, auch wenn die jetzt nicht würde ich jetzt mal sagen,
nicht institutionellen Charakter hatten. Also es gab da jetzt nicht sozusagen irgendwie eine eine offizielles Verhältnis zwischen dem Club, sondern es war basierte im Wesentlichen alles einfach auf persönlichen äh Bekanntschaften und Freundschaften. Von daher,
umfassendes Verständnis davon würde ich jetzt mal sagen,
wer da letztlich die Geschicke äh leitet, auch wenn's vollkommen klar ist, dass ähm also im Maniel Golz sieht es ja nur sein Deckname eigentlich äh Eric Eric Corly ähm.
Benannt nach äh Goldsteen aus äh Nightin Ati.
Genannt. Ist halt eigentlich schon eben die Kategorie unbeugsamer äh Hacker, der
die 'ne klare Linie verfolgt hat, ob das jetzt mal sozusagen für das unmittelbare Umfeld zutrifft, dass es dann 'ne ganz andere Frage.
Die haben natürlich auch ihre schwarzen Schafe und dieser Adrian Lemo gehört zu diesem Umfeld oder gehörte, das lässt sich von hier aus schwer beurteilen.
Na er ist jetzt wohl irgendwie, wenn ich das richtig sehe als nach dem Vorwurf der des Abgreifens oder Missbrauchs der Nutzerdaten äh von dieser von dieser Rolle da entbunden worden. Ich war nur völlig.
Also also dass irgendjemand auf dieser Erde Adrian Lemo noch mit irgendetwas vertrauen würde,
war mir war für mich unvorstellbar.
Weil das so ungefähr ähm also für diesen Menschen und seine Handlungen habe ich äh nur sehr wenig Verständnis und keinerlei äh keinerlei Wertschätzung äh.
Wertschätzung.
Übrig. Und dass der überhaupt noch geduldet wird, äh empfinde ich als äh stark überraschend.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob er, ob er da geduldet wird.
Na ja, wenn äh na ja, die haben ihn jetzt halt da rausgekegelt, aus als Administrator dieser Gruppe, da sehen wir einen Monat her. Und ähm.
Mich war äh da auch kurz mit ihm im Austausch zu, dass ich sagte, ich kann mir das also wirklich nicht vorstellen
Und er bewahrt dann, dass er äh keinerlei äh Misskontakt in den zehn Jahren seiner Administratorenschaft dort bezichtigt worden sei und äh das Vertrauen aller genieße und das halte ich für äh für schwer vorstellbar und zeigt auch mal vielleicht wieder das ähm,
dass es in dieser US-Szene dann doch einige kulturelle Unterschiede gibt, die ähm mit mit dem deutschen Hintergrund immer nur äh schwer nachvollziehbar sind.
Ja, in der Tat.
War er an. Ich weiß nicht, wir haben.
Ich freue mich wie, wie offiziell äh diese Seite da ist, weil auf Facebook, da werden ja liegen ja alle Leute, alle möglichen Leute, alle möglichen.
Ist auch völlig egal. Also das das Facebook den Typen auf seine Plattform lässt, ist allein schon eine Frechheit.
Na ja, das ist doch staatstragend.
Also ich weiß nicht mehr genau, ob es das noch ähm.
Ob der Aufruf noch ähm aktuell ist, euch weiß, dass wir eine Zeit lang gab's dann auch immer bei den Kongressen und so äh die ausliegenden Karten, wo man äh an Shetsy Meding schreiben konnte,
und ähm ich bin gerade mal am überlegen, ob das also ob's das überhaupt noch so gibt,
Adresse. Aber die Adresse, die da steht, scheint immer noch die zu sein, äh wo sie sich auch jetzt bis zuletzt aufgehalten hat, nämlich die,
Ford Leven Worse und jetzt habe ich hier gesagt, das wäre Florida. Jetzt steht hier aber kein.
Habe ich wahrscheinlich von Leven World mit Ford Lorda Day verwechselt. Ähm okay ähm,
Ich suche das nochmal gleich nach der Sendung raus, aber da kann man, glaube ich, jetzt mal gerade eine freundliche Karte hinschicken äh wie man weiß, werden Karten und Briefe, die man in Militärgefängnisse schickt, gelesen. Also
beschränkt euch da, wenn dann auf ähm freundliche Worte äh die die Person jetzt äh sicherlich,
gut gebrauchen kann, das geht mir persönlich echt. Ein bisschen nah, nicht zuletzt äh ist es ja auch eine Person,
mit der wir uns als Chaos-Computerclub schmücken als äh eines unserer Ehrenmitglieder.
Dann gibt's noch ein bisschen Neues aus den Neuss aus dem aus der Welt der des Geheimen.
Ähm zwei Neuigkeiten aus der Welt ist geheim und zwar ähm,
Als zweitausenddreizehn die Edward Snowden, Enthüllungen, so das Licht der Welt entblickten und noch ganz frisch fahren. Da hat dann der damals noch äh im Ehenamt und würden stehende Datenschutzbeauftragte Peter Schar,
Eine Abordnung in die Abhörstation äh Bad Aibling, also die Abhörstation des Bundesnachrichtendienstes in Bad Aiblingen entsendet und hat gesagt, äh schaut euch doch hier mal um, dann sind sie im Oktober zwanzig vierzehn noch einmal dort vorbeigelaufen,
und im Juli zwanzig fünfzehn,
haben sie dann schließlich ein sehr umfangreichen Sachstandsbericht verfasst, der wegen der technischen Details, die sich darin befinden äh als streng geheim,
eingestuft wurde. Ja, also da haben sie eben mal Tacheles geredet und gesagt, hier da ist das und deswegen ist das ein Datenschutzverstoß und hier das und so weiter.
Und im März zwanzig sechzehn hat dann die äh,
In Zwischenzeit zur Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten ernannte Andrea Voßhoff eine rechtliche Bewertung zu dem Sachstand aufgeschrieben, die sechzig Seiten umfängt. Also sehr viel dünner. Ähm,
und,
bereinigt um die technischen Details und man munkelt, dass sie darin sehr klare, eindeutige Urteile über die Erkenntnisse ihrer Mitarbeiter,
liefert. Ohne ein Blatt vor den Mund zu nehmen. Auch dieser Bericht wurde aber als Geheim eingestuft.
Und nun fordert der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, dass diese geheime Einstufung aufgehoben wird, damit zumindest oder dass zumindest die wesentlichen Urteile,
ähm öffentlich zugänglich werden.
Also die Kernaussagen sozusagen wie alles sozusagen aus ihrer Perspektive zu bewerten.
Was da ist. So und jetzt sagen aber die äh äh,
Die Bundesregierung sagt aber dann na ja, auch in der Rechtsbewertung werden ja sachliche wird ja Bezug genommen auf sachliche Aspekte. Und diese Sachlichen Aspekte seien ja geheim,
Und somit seien auch die Bewertungen geheim,
Und so sei nun einmal die Geheimschutzverordnung. Ähm und mehr kann man dazu auch nicht sagen, weil ist geheim. Und das ist echt, das ist echt geil, ja? Also da, das heißt, der BND macht da offenbar äh rechtswidrige,
rechtswidrige Dinge.
Verurteilungswürdige Dinge.
Rechtlich zu beurteilende Dinge und Andrea Vossov sagte, geht so nicht.
Das verstößt gegen das Gesetz und dann sagt die Bundesregierung, ja.
Vielen Dank für ihren Kommentar. Wir haben.
Ja geheim, was der was sie machen und deswegen dürfen sie. Und deswegen ist auch die Bewertung, dass das illegal ist, geheim und deswegen darf das jetzt nicht an die Öffentlichkeit.
Ist echt grandios.
Und na ja, also,
Es gibt eben ein so, es gibt einen sehr schön formulierter Artikel und wie das so ist bei äh bei schön formulierten Artikeln fällt einem dann häufig auf, dass der Autor mal wieder Kai Biermann ist und er schließt mit den Worten,
äh nee, er stieß gar nicht damit, äh aber er hat da diesen schönen Satz drin. War es ideal, was der Bundesnachrichtendienst in Bad Aiblingen ausspionierte
Verstießen Beispiel beispielsweise die NSA-Suchworte, die er benutzte gegen deutsche Gesetze? Es gibt eine unabhängige Kontrollbehäuterbehörde hierzulande und die hat dazu eine fundierte und klare Meinung
Aber diese Meinung darf die Öffentlichkeit nicht erfahren. Er schließt sich damit, sondern er,
Er öffnet sein Artikel damit. Na ja, ähm sehr schön, neues äh neues aus dem,
aus dem aus Brasilien würde ich sagen.
Ja, er schließt dann mit äh Mutmaßungen darüber, was die Opposition denn nun äh tun kann, um dieses Dilemma aufzulösen, aber das würde ja eh dauern und bis dahin ist ja das neue BND-Gesetz, äh, der großen Koalition,
schon bald beschlossen.
Ist es ja auch, ja.
Dünn ist es, vielleicht halt auch nicht mehr äh geheim, weil dann ist ja nicht so schlimm, dann ist das ja alles erlaubt.
Das ist so, also wie man da, wie man dieses Spiel ja noch eine Neuigkeit aus dem Welt des Geheimen, das dann auch die letzte Neuigkeit ähm.
In Berliner Landtag wurde am siebenundzwanzigsten April im Ausschuss für Europa und Bundesangelegenheit äh auf Antrag der Linken die Frage diskutiert,
Die Landesverratsermittlung gegen zwei Journalisten von Netzpolitik Ork Unterkenntnis des Senates stattfanden oder wie viel,
der Senat darüber wusste. Und äh von dieser Anhörung oder von dieser Besprechung am siebenundzwanzigsten April,
ist jetzt das Wort Protokoll online und dort äh,
kennt der Staatssekretär für Justiz, der Senatsverwaltung für,
Justiz Berlin, Alexander Strassmeier, Straßmeier. Ähm das die Ermittlungen der Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft gegen unbekannt eingestellt worden.
Das heißt, wer auch immer die Quelle ist, ähm es gibt zumindest keine offiziellen Ermittlungen mehr. Was heißt das?
Ähm es gibt also keine aktive Suche mehr nach äh der Quelle. Wenn sich nun
Also damit ist sie, ist es formal abgeschlossen. Es sei denn, es täten sich jetzt nun äh neue
Ermittlungsansätze auf. Also beispielsweise die Quelle hätte sich jetzt Adrian Lemo angetraut und Adrian Lemo würde äh,
das Ganze äh jetzt der Bundesregierung äh im im in einem Anflug von gewissen ähm,
erzählen, dann würden Ermittlungen wieder aufgenommen, aber formal ist dieser Ermittlungsakt jetzt angeschlossen, abgeschlossen und äh wir wissen ja, dass,
Allein im Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz mehrere oder mehrere hundert Personen Zugang zu diesen,
von André und Markus veröffentlichten Dokumenten hatten und all die waren ja quasi auch im Kreise der Verdächtigen und es gab eben jetzt keine Möglichkeit, da auszusieben und deswegen wurde dieses Ermittlungsverfahren.
Eingestellt. Das heißt offiziell kann man also jetzt sagen, diese Landesverratsaffäre ist zu einem Ende gekommen.
Na ja, also es wird zumindest nicht ermittelt, aber es könnte sozusagen in dem Moment, wo neue Verdachtsmomente auftauchen äh könnte es wieder aufgegriffen werden. Das ist, sagen wir mal, juristisch noch nicht komplett tot, aber es ist sozusagen erstmal Ruhe einge.
Solange das nicht verjährt ist, ne? Also es gibt ja dann auch eine Verjährungsfrist, ich weiß nicht genau, äh wie lang die ist. Ähm.
Drei Jahre wahrscheinlich.
Paar Jahre und wenn jetzt so dann aber da kann also jetzt jemand aufatmen.
Ja. Eine oder mehrere. Wir können auch aufatmen, denn wir haben uns wieder durch den Mist gegraben.
Ja
Riecht auch schon wieder so ein bisschen.
Weil's so heiß ist hier,
Ist warm gerade. Ja.
Welche jetzt noch ein Kaltgetränk anbieten.
Habe ich ja gerade schon geguckt, siehst ja nichts im Kühlschrank.
Ne? Ja, Versorgung bricht zusammen hier in der Mittebene.
Unter welchen Bedingungen wir hier arbeiten, habe ich eigentlich noch irgendwas äh halt kaufen, was allgemeines loszuwerden.
Was hier noch ein Danke.
Danke, ja, danke, aber das Danke kommt ja erst, war ganz am Ende.
Ja, wir sind doch schon am Ende.
Ja, aber noch irgendwelche.
Nun liebe Kinder, geht schön schlafen.
Ich überlege gerade, habe ich noch irgendwas? Nee, ich habe jetzt, glaube ich, genug über Dinge aufgeregt.
Ja, du hast nicht genug aufgeregt. Ja, so äh lassen wir euch äh zurück.
Und macht was draus.
Macht was draus, ja.
Nehmt euch die die Schweizer Büpfer, Antibüpfer äh zum Vorbild und überlegt, wo ihr noch etwas anrichten könnt mit ein paar,
Mit ein paar Leuten, die euch zusammen rottet und äh wirksame Möglichkeiten des Protests ausprobiert. Und des Widerstands.
In diesem Sinne.
Danken wir Dennis. Danke ich Dennis.
Dennis. Ich danke allen anderen und äh das ist gemein. Mir bleibt.
Das ist gemein. Ich dachte allen anderen.
Auch allen anderen muss irgendwann mal gedankt werden.
Sei ich eben auch gepankt.
So ist es. Tschüss Leute, bis bald.
Auf Wiederhören.